hello everyone and welcome back to the
2019 isle of man chess tournament a lot
of you have requested this game well
yeah a lot of you have requested other
games as well but this game has been
requested the most so I decided to show
this one and it's a Russian grand
mastery of gaining ir vs. Uche marathon
Anand gnar is the 2015 European champion
so definitely a strong player his peak
rating is over 2700 but at at the moment
he's somewhere around 26 30 definitely
the underdog in this matchup and before
we check out the game I would just like
to share something that I've seen today
today is a world obesity day but also in
the United States its national sausage
beats a day so I thought this was very
interesting so I decided to share it
with you to have to have a national
sausage pizza day on world obesity day
so you know if you thought that that's
interesting you might also want to share
it with your friends at the bar and the
library so that being said let's check
out the game now with the white pieces
opens with d4 we have Knight to f6 c4 e6
Knight to c3 and the Bishop to b4 the
nimzo-indian defense is on the board
with III by Nayer on earth castles and
now Bishop the d2 are developing the
bishop on pinning and now d5 by Anand
with Knight to f3 continuing development
b6 by Anand preparing to fianchetto his
LightSquared bishop and rook the c1 with
Bishop to d7 by Anand and now one trade
in the center seek a press on d5 with
ecad first on d5 and now Bishop to d3
preparing the castle developing the
light square bishop and here Anand goes
back Bishop to e7 which is a which is a
nice idea you want the bishop to be able
to help out with the defense and also
there are no more pins here so it's not
very useful and you will not be wasting
any tempo at MP as black or white dark
square Bishop is also not optimally
placed on d2 and also I would just like
to mention that Knights the e4 doesn't
work here it seems like something you
want to do especially you know in a
names of Indian but after Knight
captures you cannot trade here that's
the problem one of the
- appear as a white we'll just recapture
and it will be done a piece and if D
captures captures done before attacks
the rook you have rook to e8 and now
Bishop to b5 going after the rook but
now for example if black goes he
captures an f3 Bishop captures an e 8f
captures and g2 and now Bishop captures
an f7 width check King captures and now
Queen to h5 check King to g8 and rook to
g1 you would get this crazy position
where white is up the exchange and since
black doesn't really have any
development just yet and not not in any
good ways to take advantage of the white
king still being in the center of the
board white will be better here so just
in case if you were wondering about
Knight e4 here push back the e7 by Anand
and now castles by Nayer we have Knight
B to d7 and now Knight to e5 a standard
idea you want to get this beautiful
outpost for your knight you want to
cement it in with f4 and Anand has to
decide whether he wants to keep the
knight on e5 maybe try to wiggle around
the position maybe try to kick it away
in the future with f6 but it's a very
very unlikely as if you've ever played
position where your opponent has a
knight on e5 it's really hard to kick it
away from there
so here Anand decides to just capture it
with Knight captures on e5 d captures on
e5 Knight to d7 attacking d5 pawn and
now Nigel defends it with f4 and this is
now a very pleasant position for white
and black has to decide how to go about
it first
Anand goes the Knights of the c5
threatens the bishop here and the narrow
just tucks it in for later we've pushed
back to be 1 just keeping it on the
board it's it's a beautiful Bishop and
now d4 by Anand this has all been played
before so no new ideas here attacking
the knight affecting these reported here
Knights the b5 threatening to now just
win win the pawn and fix the pawn
structure and here's the problem Anand
cannot trade here for example if he
trades a bishop characters you will
constantly have a problem of this Knight
and rook attacking the c7 point B for is
a is a pretty big big threat the knight
will have to move you will just win
material even if you trade Queens it
doesn't really help you
rook s capture some d1 and now how do
you defend it there
there's no good way you can either play
something like rook a to see it or rook
F to see it and then just be for kicks
the knight wait you win the c-7 pawn or
if you try something like c6 which saves
the c7 point but then you give the
control of the d6 square to white 96 and
this is just a beautiful position for
white
so after Knight to b5 you cannot trade a
nun decides to push the pawn d3 and with
this book on and created a very nice
path pawn on d3 so what do you do now
before now isn't all that great if you
try and force this idea of B for now for
example Knight to e4 and Knight captures
on c7 just look to see it your knight is
under attack you have to move it and now
Queen to d5 will be very strong you have
this beautiful Queen Bishop battery
threatening made after the knight moves
also the knight is under attack here and
black would be just much better here
so here Nayar goes for a different idea
after d3 he goes Knight back to d4 now
with ideas of Queen to g4 followed by
Knight to f5 with some attacking chances
on the King side and here aren't could
go Quinta Quinta d5 threaten checkmate
and I would prevent it with Queen to g4
as the Queen wants to come to g4 either
way but first on the secure assist
position on the Queen side he plays a 5
B 4 is no longer a threat and only then
will he decide what to do on the Kings
side and in the center with queen g4 by
Nayer now preparing Knight to f5 and g6
of course you don't want to allow this
but now you allow a different type of
attack with f5 by Nayer and now white
still has the bishop pair although for
the moment the bishop pair isn't doing
all that much this light for Bishop is
pretty bad and for the moment the darks
were bishop also not doing all the great
so here again on untested estar what to
do whether he wants to go Queen to d5
and take it from there or he wants to
improve the his pieces and maybe only
then bring the Queen to d5 he goes
Knight to e4 he says ok first let's see
what you you want to do with your Bishop
on d2 and nar has a very nice idea about
what to do with the bishop on d2 now
plays a Bishop captures and d3 he
sacrifices
depandi - so already as a move 19 we
have a peace sacrifice so on and went
for it there is nothing better he has to
capture the bishop and accept the
sacrifice and now we have f captures and
g6 so here you have to ask yourselves
can you go for the rook as well it's a
very complicated line for example if you
capture the rook then do you see how
white proceeds in this position I'll
give you a couple of seconds you can
pause the video and try to continue this
attack with white if if the the rook was
captured so for those who are able to do
it congratulations and finding a winning
move in a line that never happened over
the board and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's night II 6
just a deadly move threatening
everything here and after the knight is
captured it the point is just to remove
the f7 pawn then Queen to h5 and there
is no defense here you can try to
prolong the game with rook f7 but it
will not help you just pawn captures
with checking f8 check in captures check
once again now that you've removed the
f7 plunking f8 and now you're gonna
capture rook captures an f1 with the
check and there's nothing better here
captures captures and now you're getting
either made it or you have to give up
the Queen and now why this again just
the completely winning it will be made
very quickly so here you cannot capture
the rook on the side and F captures an
g6 is up a piece he wants to trade even
more material so how do you continue
this attack again you're white what do
you play here I'm sure you can do it
without even pausing the video
it's Bishop captures on g6 of course and
now again you have to ask yourselves
what can you do here what are the
threats of course some very nasty
discoveries are possible if the bishop
moves so here unemployed King to h8 also
a possible line was Bishop to see it
this is what I called the Polaris when a
bishop retreats to the back rank to help
out with the defense I call it the pole
carriers because of a very special game
I enjoy it's a Rudolph Spillman versus
Paul Karras if you haven't seen it I do
have it on my channel it will be the
first link in the description below
check it out beautiful counter-attacking
game by paul harris but it was a
possibility bishop
and then for a night to a five you block
the attack Bishop captures rook captures
here on would get a chance to trade a
lot of pieces the Bishop captures and
the now King to h8 but after rook to d1
on and keeps the extra piece but it will
be very hard he will have to play
extremely precise but it was a
possibility
Anand decides for King to a trade first
he says okay I'm not allowing you any
discoveries but Nayar continues in his
relentless attack Bishop captures on h7
so again what do you do here here on and
decides to trade a pair of rooks rook
captures an f1 with rook captures an f1
and now can uh none grab the other look
as well well if you capture a knight
captures on f1 you get Bishop to g6
would ideas of Queen h5 checks followed
by Queen h7 and Queen to f8 mate Queen
to f7 mate so you would have to try and
block it somehow let's say Queen g8 but
it doesn't help you check you'll go to
g7 you will get a nice to f5 check the
knight joins the attack King f8 and now
Queen to h6 check you will have to block
and Queen captures is mate as there is
nothing more to be done here
so Anand has to figure out how to how to
get out of all this mess he plays Bishop
to g5 he wants to get the bishop over to
h6 and help out with the defense this
way because the night is coming either
to e6 or f5 you will have problems
guarding the g7 square so Knights the f5
by Nayer and the now comes Queen to d3
not only threatening mate and f1 but
also preparing the other rook so the
arrow can enter the game here an hour
has to take a take a step back from the
attack and guard the the main threat he
plays the rook to e1 and now undergoes
for Bishop captures on e3 with check of
course you cannot move the rule because
Queen to f1 would still be made so what
do you do here if you capture with the
knife then Queen captures on h7 stops
the attack so what can you do here keep
the h1 there are no more checks here and
now Anand has to guard the maid threat
so he goes back the shop to h7 again if
you capture it then the Queen can just
capture the bishop here it's not a
problem and here we have Queen to Jesus
bye-bye now now preparing this nasty
idea of Queen f6 check once the King
captures the bishop Queen will capture
on h6 with check and then or just the
yeah we capture on h6 with check and
then follow it up by Queen to g7 mate so
Anand has to figure out how to defend
against this he plays Bishop captures on
g2 with check and here's a very critical
moment of how to continue this game for
now once again you can just try and
pause the video and figure out how you
would recapture the bishop or will you
even recapture it for those of you who
decided to capture it with the king that
is exactly what an hour played but it is
not the most correct move the correct
move is the captured with the Queen and
now you have to go into this Lion King
captures on h7 night chapters on h6 and
now Queen f3 just trade Queens and now
for example if Knight to g4 you can save
the night now the the knight is
protected now Queen character screen
captures and you get this end game where
the matter on the board is equal but
white is up upon I mean it's equal
pieces wise but what is up opponent it's
a very strong pass pawn so the white
would have excellent winning chances
here but of course now is reluctant to
you know go back from this idea if you
can just get this Queen to f6 check in
he wins the game so he plays King
captures and g2 but now he allows on a
very sneaky defensive idea so feel free
to pause the video once again I know I'm
asking you to pause the video a lot here
but there are a lot of very cool ideas
here so feel free to pause the video and
try to find an excellent defensive move
for Anand while I give you a couple of
seconds for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on being such a
brilliant defender and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show its
Queen to f3 check point is after King TG
1 you have Queen to f4 this Queen to f4
move is such a hard move to find it's
it's a necessary defensive resource
because it guards the
dh6 bishop now after Queen to f6 White
will have nothing better for example
King captures now you don't have this
amazing idea of capturing on h6 a white
will have to be satisfied with
a repetition here so after kink after
Sanji - quinta after we check a best
idea for Anand but Anand played Queen to
d5 check instead probably to leave the F
3 square vacated for the night so you
can use it also as an attacking piece
but the problem is neither now has King
to h3 Anand continuous Queen to d3 check
but not on our place King to h4 and it
was in this position that we found and
resigned the game and pretty big upset
happened in round 1 as if Jenny and I
are takes down a former world champion
which were not an island here honored
resigns even though Anand had some 10
minutes on the clock whereas Nayar had a
minute and a half he decided there was
no point in continuing because there is
no good defense here for example Queen D
8-track o is just met with King - h5 and
now if you trade Queens Queen to g5
checked Queen captures Bishop captures
now Bush up to g6 just wins as you don't
have any good way of stopping the path
pawn all of the squares are poverty 7 is
covered by the night he ate is covered
by the bishop so it's an easy win if you
try Knight f3 the guarded Bishop and
attack the rook just look if one wins
apiece
you can't save both the knight and the
bishop you would have to go after the
first pawn and now King captures your
just upper piece three bonds each it's
an easy win on the other hand after King
to h4 if you don't go Queen to d8 check
you might also try Knight to f3 check it
is possible but after King h5 there are
no more checks and you don't have a good
move here whatever you play Queen f6 is
coming you can try Roka fate it does
prevent mate for a moment but Queen
captures on h6 again what do you play
here rope to f7 you have to play
something bunch of g6 check King g8 and
now just captures captures and the Queen
to f6 check wherever you go you're
getting made it with the Queen so
nothing nothing to do here every line in
ends in mate for an iron and I I decided
to award an eye or the morphe head as he
played such a beautiful relentless
attack I didn't want to give him the
more if he had before we finish the game
as it would maybe spoil the video too
much but here it is
negate the morphe head and I do hope you
agree that he deserves this as it was
just a beautiful attack even though
Anand had chances but as it always is
with beautiful attacks there is always
that one moment where you can defend but
if you don't take your chance like on
and missed the Queen f3 he plays 25 then
the attack just prevails yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank John cousins and Barry
Malone for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thankful for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Isle of
Man Tournament to checking up on your
suggestions and preparing the next big
saga thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day